-Our next guest is a hilarious
comedian, writer,
and Emmy-nominated host
of the Netflix show "Nailed It!"
She also hosts
the TBS show "Wipeout,"
as well as the podcast
"Why Won't You Date Me?"
Please welcome back to the sho
one of our favorites,
Nicole Byer.
How are you, Nicole?
-Hi, Seth, how are you?
-I'm wonderful, and I
desperately want to talk to yo
about your television show
but I am also aware
that you have
a different TV show
that you are currently
obsessed with.
Could you tell us
a little about that?
-I am obsessed
with Tyler Perry's "The Oval."
Okay, Seth, have you seen it
-I did not know it existed
-Okay, so,
it's a White House drama.
He rebuilt the White House
80% to scale.
And then in the pilot,
a kid gets kidnapped.
There's a cult. There's
cheating. There's slapping
It is honestly --
It's a wild ride.
I love it so much.
-How many episodes of "The Oval"
have happened?
-Uh, Tyler Perry works
very fast, very, very fast
I think there's like 30 episodes
or something like that.
And it's only happened
within like the last two years
It's truly so wild.
-God, I love him.
It's just amazing what he does
-He's incredible.
I worship at the altar
of Tyler Perry!
-Well, we worship
at the altar of Nicole Bye
over here at "Late Night."
You are hosting "Wipeout"
right now.
This is people
with far too much confidence
that they can complete
an obstacle course.
Have you even gone near trying
to do the course yourself?
-So, I asked.
Before we started,
I said, "Please let me do it
It will be so funny."
And then three weeks
before we started shooting
I fell down my stairs
and dislocated my ankle.
My foot was, like, on backwards.
So they were like,
"Nicole, that's a no.
You can't even walk down stairs.
What makes you think you can d
a full-blown obstacle course?"
And I was like "Uh-huh, yeah
you guys are right."
-Yeah, there should be
a different show
called "Light Wipeout,"
which is just stairs,
a rug on a slippery floor.
-Yeah, it's just, like,
walking in heels.
It's like, "Can you do it?
The answer for me is no.
-Wait. You fell off
a motorcycle, though.
What was that?
-Yeah. So, I fell
off a motorcycle twice.
One of my dear friends,
Meatball --
She's a drag queen. That's not
her government name --
But she's got a motorcycle
She was like, "Nicole, get on.
And I said, "Okay."
And I was doing really well,
and the last thing I heard was
"Diva, you're killing it."
And then I just
took this turn too hard.
And I was like,
"I'm crashing into a fence."
And then I heard, "Diva, no!
And then the second time
was during my road test.
If you fall off a motorcycle
during your road test, you fail.
-That seems fair.
But you actually went so far
after your first fall
to try to get a license for it
-Yeah, and then after
I fell the second time,
I bought a motorcycle.
So, is my brain
working correctly?
We'll never know.
-Have you always been interested
in motorcycles and cars?
-Yeah. When I was a kid, I
wanted to be, like, a mechanic
or, like, a very sassy
bus driver with long nails
And I'd be like, "Beep, beep
get on the bus!"
[ Both laugh ]
-Now, probably not a school bus.
As we have discussed before,
children like you.
You do not care for children
-No.
Uh, no offense. They're sticky
They're very dumb.
Like, that's not me being rude
You literally have to
teach kids everything.
Otherwise,
they don't know anything.
But I keep getting booked
on these things.
I'm doing "Rugrats."
Kids love "Nailed It!"
I'm doing a lot
of cartoon voices.
I don't know. Maybe I'm going to
have to learn to love kids
I don't want to.
-What shows did you watch
as a kids?
Were you a "Rugrats" fan?
-I was not a "Rugrats" fan
I didn't have cable growing up
So, if I went to a friends
house, and "Rugrats" was on,
I'd be like, "Oh, wow.
This is luxury. I love this.
When I was a kid, I watche
what my mom watched,
and she loved "Ally McBeal."
Loved. Like, I just discovered
that the dancing baby
was not just a dancing baby --
It was a woman wanting a baby.
[ Both laugh ]
I was like,
"Ooh, this baby fun."
-You also have a podcast calle
"Why Won't You Date Me?"
And I think a lot of peopl
are very excited
for what dating might look lik
now that we are
getting our vaccines,
now that we can have
physical contact again.
Are you excited
about what's next?
-I am so excited.
I am fully vaccinated.
I have no standards.
This summer,
I want every hole filled.
That is it. That's just --
That's what I want.
All of them. I don't want
to be able to speak!
-Thank you for using
your "Rugrats" catchphrase
"I want every hole filled.
[ Laughter ]
God, please don't let the kids
connect the dots now.
That's very --
Another thing that's excitin
is getting up, doing stand-u
in front of audiences again.
Seems like that's
going to start happening.
Are you excited?
Are you worried you'll be rusty?
-I'm a little worried
about being rusty.
But I've, like, been going
through my sets, transcribing.
The thing I'm, like,
most afraid of
is people during meet-and-greets
wanting to touch me.
I like the bubble.
I like the six feet away.
I like masks. Don't touch me
-That seems very at odds
with the last thing you told us.
[ Laughter ]
-Unless you filling something,
stay away from me!
-[ Laughs ]
You know, I will tell you,
I did a little stand-up
a couple weeks ago.
And it's so thrilling
how excited people are
to just watch anything.
Like, I don't know
if I was any good.
People were just
so thirsty for content.
-[ Laughs ]
Yeah, I've done a couple
outdoor shows, and people --
They get excited,
and then they're just, like,
willing to listen,
which is so nice.
-Yeah. It's also so nice,
because I feel like,
during the pandemic,
you would tell people
how your pandemic was,
and then you'd have to
listen to them tell you.
And with stand-up,
you just get to tell them.
-Which I love.
The last show I did, I was like,
"We're going to talk about 2020,
'cause it ruined my life.
It was very awful,
and you have to listen."
And they were like, "Yes!"
And I was like,
"This is perfect.
This is a dream."
It's like therapy
but with a bunch of people
who don't talk back.
-Well, it is always like therapy
for us to see you, as well
We do hope that you will make it
back here into our studio
one of these days.
And thank you so much
for making the time for us
-Aww, Seth, thank you
for having me.
This is a treat.
-A special live version
of "Why Won't You Date Me?
is available on-demand
for the next seven days
at live.nicolebyerwastaken.com